well Hans welcome back to the show you
tweeted before the round it's time to
let the chess pick for itself did the
chess pick for itself in this
game
no tell us about the game HS how do you
feel about the result how do you feel
about all this Dynamic play that you
guys have been engaging in for the last
few
hours yeah I think um the only moment
that I'm really thinking about is uh
when I played
U Queen F5 I think a full Rook sacrifice
with Knight takes G5 there U might have
been winning or that's it that's that's
what I'm that's what I've been thinking
about you actually wanted to play that
move you were I second away you uh
hinted at touching that pawn and picking
it off the board yeah I just hesitated
uh I
wanted yeah I thought that um Queen F5 I
could never lose nine takes G5 was
obviously there some risk but
I think it just had to be the it it had
to be the it was just
the I thought it had to be the right
move because take Rook of one I'm down a
rook but uh everything is coming just uh
instinctively I think it has to be
winning but um obviously when you have
two seconds uh it's very difficult to to
make such difficult decisions yes and
even after Queen to F5 you said that it
wasn't losable but in fact this position
is almost losing if he does take on F5
first he was needing to make a lot of
precise decisions with a few seconds on
his clock as well well the engine's
jumping I don't know yeah it was right
Queen takes F5 Bishop takes F5 take on
C5 and it does seem like black is
winning yeah
knight4 knight4 was UN clear knight4
only move this is not easy stuff not
easy stuff no it's very difficult
especially with no time yes I thought A6
no A6 A6
Maybe A6 Bishop F7 seems to be Bishop F7
okay
interesting again not easy stuff how did
you feel In the Heat of the battle right
now did you consider yourself the
favorite did you think you have the
better position how did you see these
last few moves of the time trouble
situation C things certainly went wrong
because I felt in the opening I I was
outplaying him to quite a serious degree
uh I'm just can you just tell me what
Knight takes G5 with the engine said
after that I'm just curious yes uh
Knight takes G5 was in in fact plus two
and a half take and then Rook to
F1 he has to be very precise has to go
Queen to F7 Rook F5 King to h8 now all
of your pieces are coming Knight to E4
and it's very difficult for black
especially with with no time yeah I I
should have gone for something like this
because uh he's just uh it's it's very
easy for him to collapse and my moves
are quite simple so
uh I should have uh trusted my instinct
there but but uh yeah as soon as I
played it um I understood that it was it
was a serious mistake H you're coming
from the world juniors uh in Mexico that
was a very taxing event in terms of your
energy levels how are you feeling right
now did you get enough time to replenish
your energy
tank no I I feel fine I feel good I
think I played very well this game I
just um didn't manage my time to the
best of my ability and
then things started to go wrong when U I
lost the the control um but I think in
general I feel that I played a very good
game up until this point and uh I just
need to be uh more lethal when it comes
to
converting krina yeah Hans I don't want
to be too annoying but I really want to
just ask uh about the move Knight a G5
because it looked like you were about to
capture that pawn and make that move and
then you switched what was the reason uh
what was the decision that like changed
it from one second to the other I just
thought that I should
um I I obviously understood that I had a
much better position um I thought that
Queen F5 was a risk-free way to play on
so uh maybe I'm getting old and uh
afraid so I have to go back to my uh uh
impulsive instincts of playing for when
at all cost so it's it's hard to balance
that um um because you know uh ambition
uh is double sword um but uh okay I had
two seconds on the clock it was a split
second decision um usually uh you try to
keep things simple um but at least I'm
very happy with how I played and I'm
happy that at least I I understood how
uh uh good knightx G5 was regardless of
whether I played it or not so I think
that's a good sign for my
form yeah it was an amazing game
absolutely Hans I thought it was a great
great game it was wonderful enjoyable to
call and all I can say is good luck in
the future rounds this what you kept
this on our edge of our seats and uh
when you replay our broadcast you can
see yourself actually you were reaching
for Knight takes G5 and then split
seconds you played Queen F5 uh to try to
keep
control so thank you and uh we'll see
you
tomorrow and back to uh we do have Alice
Lee uh do we